.
>> OR SLEEP OR WANT TO GO HOME.
>> IT'S FRIDAY.
>> SO THERE IS A POOL GOING ON
IN THE MAKEUP ROOM ABOUT HOW
LONG THIS IS GOING LAST.
I DON'T HAVE TO ASK YOU WHAT YOU
VOTED FOR, BUT, JUST LOOKING AT
THE HISTORY OF THIS, WHICH I
HAVE HAD TIME TO DO ON THE
MICROFICHE THAT DANA HAS
REFERRED TO, THERE ARE ONLY A
FEW WAYS IN WHICH THIS KIND OF
THING GETS RESOLVED.
ONE OF THEM IS CHANGING THE
RULES.
THAT'S HOW THEY ENDED THE 133
VOTE, ONE THAT LASTED TWO
MONTHS, AND 64 VOTES, WHICH IS
REQUIRING A PLURALITY, INSTEAD
OF A MAJORITY.
ONE OF THEM IS FINDING CONSENSUS
CANDIDATE.
AND ONE OF THEM IS JUST GRINDING
IT OUT.
I'M KIND OF THE BELIEF THAT THIS
IS GOING TO BE A GRINDOUT.
THAT IT'S GOING TO GO AND GO AND
GO UNTIL SOMEBODY BLINKS.
>> HOW MANY BALLOTS.
GO AHEAD.
GIVE IT UP.
WHAT DID YOU SAY IN THE POOL,
JAKE?
SNOUM.
>> >> YOU MISSED THE POOL.
>> JAKE, HOW MANY BALLOTS DID
YOU GUESS?
>> I SAID 29.
BUT THAT'S BECAUSE I KEPT GOING
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN 39 AND
19.
AND FINALLY I MADE A COMPROMISE.
BUT BECAUSE I THINK ULTIMATELY,
I MEAN, 29 UNTIL THEY GET A
SPEAKER.
I MEAN, THAT'S NOT TO SAY KEVIN
McCARTHY IS GOING TO LAST UNTIL
29, OR THAT HE WON'T.
MAYBE HE WILL.
BUT I JUST THINK THEY SEEM VERY,
VERY DUG IN, AND THERE SEEM TO
BE AT LEAST FIVE OR SIX HOUSE
REPUBLICANS THAT WILL NEVER VOTE
FOR KEVIN McCARTHY.
AND I CAN'T UNDERSTAND HOW THOSE
FIVE OR SIX ARE GOING TO CHANGE.
OR EVEN IF IT'S ONLY FIVE.
>> RIGHT.
>> HE CAN ONLY LOSE FOUR.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU VOTED.
>> SO I GUESSED 20.
I WAS A LITTLE MORE OPTIMISTIC.
BUT EVERYBODY I SPEAK TO, ALL
THE REPUBLICAN MEMBERS THAT I'M
TALKING TO, THEY ARE ALL SAYING
THEY DON'T SEE THE MATH TO GET
HIM THERE.
THEY DON'T KNOW NECESSARILY WHO
NUMBER FIVE OR SIX OR SEVEN IS
OF THE NEVER KEVINS, BUT THEY
BELIEVE THERE ARE MORE THAN
FOUR, AND THEY THINK IT'S
PERSONAL, AND THEY DON'T THINK
ANYTHING WILL CHANGE THEIR MIND.
>> IT IS POSSIBLE IF THERE WERE
A CANDIDATE LIKE STEVE SCALISE,
AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT NEXT
TIME WE COME BACK HERE, BUT IF
THERE WERE A CANDIDATE LIKE
STEVE SCALISE, MAYBE THAT WOULD
BE ENOUGH.
MAYBE THE REBELS THINK WE'VE GOT
OUR PELT.
IT'S ON THE WALL.
LET'S MOVE FORWARD.
BUT WHO KNOWS.
I DON'T KNOW.
PEOPLE LIKE LAUREN BOEBERT HAVE
SAID, ANDERSON, THEY DON'T WANT
ANYBODY IN HOUSE LEADERSHIP THAT
INCLUDES STEVE SCALISE.
>> THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
NEW YORK MAKEUP ROOM AND THE
D.C. MAKEUP ROOM, THERE IS NO
POOL.
WHO KNOW